elle est aux mains des Russes depuis le
début de l'invasion en février dernier
crelson une ville du sud de l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui annexé à des airs de
forteresse mais depuis plusieurs
semaines les troupes ukrainiennes se
rapprochent elles auraient d'après les
autorités d'occupation mener deux
frappes sur la vie et notamment sur un
barrage privant d'eau et d'électricité
plus de 10 localités dans la région de
Helson et ces derniers jours les
occupants auraient évacués des milliers
de civils de plusieurs villages aux
alentours devant l'imminence d'une
attaque ukrainienne aux missiles selon
les Russes
nous continuons de recommander fortement
aux habitants de quitter la rive droite
de rerson et la région de rerson et de
se diriger vers la rive gauche à tous
ceux qui spéculent sur des attaques nous
rappelons que la vie des citoyens de
rerson et de sa région restent notre
priorité et celle de la Fédération de
Russie
rue c'est ukrainien s'accuse
mutuellement de mettre en danger les
vies de milliers de l'habitants dans
cette région ces derniers jours devant
l'avancée des forces ukrainiennes
l'administration russe a annoncé
impossible retrait de ses soldats de
l'ouest de Welson mais pour l'armée
ukrainienne c'est une énième
manipulation russe
les Russes utilisent des tactiques pour
nous duper
ce qu'on constate sur le front c'est que
l'ennemi a renforcé ses positions grâce
aux nouveaux conscrits mobilisés ici on
sent la différence il se comporte
différemment et ne sont pas habitués à
la situation par exemple ils n'ont pas
peur des drones qu'il est survolent
vendredi les autorités russes
d'occupation ont démenti la mise en
place d'un couvre-feu à Helson